in this cloud minute I'll show you how  to export logs from stock driver logging  into cloud storage bigquery or pub/sub  exporting logs to cloud storage allows  you to store them for extended periods  of time exporting to bigquery allows you  to do more complicated analysis of your  logs and exporting pub/sub allows you to  send your logs to other applications  from the stock driver logs viewer click  on create export you can limit your  export by using the logging filters if  you need to now you need to name your  sink  you can use alphanumeric characters  underscore - and period now it's time to  select a service if you choose cloud  storage you'll be asked to pick a  storage bucket if you choose bigquery  you'll be asked to choose a data set now  click create sync logs exported to  bigquery will show up almost immediately  logs exported to cloud storage are  batched and will show up approximately  once an hour  now I can use the power of bigquery to  look deeper into my logs